Dear sam pepper,
a few weeks ago,
some hacker release nude photos of
Jennifer Lawrence and some other
celebrities,
and that's something we've seen before.
People's privacy being criminally
violated,
women being criminally objectified on
the Internet.
What was surprising was the reaction in
the days following the leak.
Over two dozen articles appeared from
different news and periodical sites with
headlines like you know who's not to
blame for Jennifer Lawrence's nude photo
leaks.
Jennifer Lawrence stopped blaming
Jennifer Lawrence and other celebrities
for taking nude photos in the first
place.
Jennifer Lawrence shouldn't laugh off
her nude photo.
Jennifer Lawrence nude pics and why you
shouldn't look.
This isn't about iphones.
This is about women being shamed,
objectified,
and treated like property.
These are what we refer to as opinion
pieces or think pieces and thanks to the
upworthy is one of the Internet.
You can pretty much get there just from
the headlines alone.
You've been a citizen of the web for the
last five or 10 years,
so you know that the ubiquity of these
pieces is growing all the time.
After any controversial event in society
or pop culture,
you can expect your facebook newsfeed to
overflow with articles like this.
Sometimes it's annoying people
expressing offense as if a fence equated
to righteousness or sites producing
content just for the sake of producing
content.
Other times,
most of the time,
like in the case of that nude photo
league,
these articles taken together,
express the politically correct view of
the issue at hand.
Now,
political correctness has a bad rap in
general conversation and like the pieces
themselves that can serve to block
dialogue instead of just started,
but political correctness is itself only
an expression of our democratic concern
for groups who are habitually and
unfairly discriminated against.
In other words,
it's an expression of morality.
What we understand to be right and wrong
at this moment in time when coupled with
the ubiquity of these think pieces,
it seems to me that socially enforced
morality has reached an entirely new
level of persuasive power for the first
time.
The majority of people.
I asked about the photo and particularly
men told me that they didn't seek out or
look at the photos in question citing
the reasons in those articles,
even if you disagreed with what they
said,
which I didn't.
Those articles served as a sort of
script for what to say to family and
friends and coworkers if you wanted to
stay in good ethical standing with the
community that they represent.
Now,
the response to your video,
Sam,
of pinching girls on the butt is of the
same vein only.
It didn't happen in online periodicals.
It happened right here on Youtube and
tumblr before it was taken down.
Your video had over double the amount of
dislikes than likes about 70,000
and my tumblr feed was spilling over
with elegant condemnations of what you
did have particular significance where
the responses of John and Hank Green,
who are never slow to speak out about
situations like this,
whether they would accept the title or
not,
the Vlog brothers have stepped forward
as moral arbiter is on a host of issues.
Even if all they do is signal boost the
opinions of others.
In the case of the marginalization of
women,
see,
for example,
the Alex Day deal,
they are never equivocal and their
community,
my community is the better for it.
Last Monday,
youtube removed your video,
Sam,
and though it clearly violated their
policy on nudity and sexual content,
there is no doubt that the public outcry
is responsible for that.
Look,
I know this is a somewhat cold analysis
of things,
but I'm fascinated by the sociological
trends at work here,
how moral perspectives move and advance
through the culture,
how and by what avenues they evolve from
dissenting to acceptable do
unquestionable and what role an internet
of commenters has to play and all that.
For the record,
I share the morality of the Vlog.
Brothers and everyone who has re
blogged,
what they've written about this,
the objectification of women is
detestable in all its kinds,
especially those which are hard to see
and insidious yet keenly felt by every
woman.
I know this is a harmful gross and
fucking tedious way to act.
There's still a long way to go,
but you and all the other Sam peppers of
the world should really read the writing
on the dashboard.
Collectively.
We've left you behind.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
The gradual evolution of morality really
is fascinating to me and it has
instruments all across the culture and
the sharpest and most vicious has got to
be South Park and a great example of an
expression of morality from the culture
is their takedown of the redskins team
name,
which appeared in a commercial during
the redskins game last week and I'll put
a link for it below.
South Park's amazing.
If you want to talk more about this,
I am always in comments for.
You can ask me anything on Tumbler.
Thanks again for watching.
I'll see you next time.